[Music]
Christmas would no be the same without a
beautiful delicious honey glazed ham
across that long Christmas period this
get you out of jail quite easily ham
salads ham sandwiches how Negin chips
this is a gammon what could do now is
cook it so it becomes a ham into a pan
first things first the water
cover it completely so the whole gammon
cooks evenly
the important part now is having flavor
in there
kerosene
a leaks the more veg in there now the
more fragrant the broth becomes once the
ham is cooked that stops his
extraordinary stir face to a fantastic
soup onion not finely chopped and then
homemade ham stock is packed with flavor
so it's great for making soups sauces
stews and risottos plus it can be frozen
so it's there when you need it
and down
[Music]
peppercorns lightly crush then to give
it a Christmas flavor I'm adding crushed
coriander seeds 2 cinnamon sticks and
for aromatic bay leaves up to the boil
and they turn it down let it simmer and
then skim it cooking it ham isn't hard
but it does take time this 2 kilo joint
takes two and a half hours to simmer
before it's glazed and baked
however it is worth it because it tastes
absolutely delicious
so the glaze very very simple Demerara
sugar Madeira that sweetens that lays
basically a four to five wine color
tablespoons in and then share vinegar
again come and tablespoons honey in nice
bring out to the ball the longer you
leave it on the stove the darker it
becomes you want your ham really nice
and dark
then cook out the glaze for three or
four minutes that I'll happy with lovely
[Music]
right the Gammons cook now onto the
plate carefully snip the string
nice and gently peel back get rid of the
skin then crisscross it don't push too
deep let the knife do the work study
with some clothes
[Music]
look at it almost looks like an albino
pineapple the blaze I'm just carefully
cover start in the middle and let it
work round gently gently gently gently
it's like a roasted yet and it looks
amazing beautiful - that half the glaze
over now into the oven 15 minutes
[Music]
it started to color okay the rest of the
blaze and pour that over look at it wow
the more efforts fashioned and loved you
show the ham now the results of tenfold
look at it every five minutes out of the
oven and blaze again a back of the oven
now a 190 degrees we're gonna baste and
roast for 35 minutes delicious
next I'm gonna make a pear and saffron
chutney this is a fruity relish that
works brilliantly with a sweet aromatic
ham versus first sliced onion finely
chopped onion in olive oil without
coloring it the important part about
this stage is the fact that we're gonna
layer the chutney with textures from
onion to apple to pair a nice little
block of ginger grating the ginger so
the Jesus sort of disappears with the
onions then have the spices a good
grating of nutmeg followed by a teaspoon
of cinnamon and a teaspoon of cayenne
pepper to give it a kick
delicious I recently spent a lot of time
in India where chutneys originated and
discovered that whereas British style
chilies tend to be cooked and are
usually quite sweet Indian ones are
normally fresh spicier and quite sour
next Demerara sugar
[Music]
what's that sugars dissolved the white
wine vinegar all in let's do it it's
really nice sort of sweet and sour
flavor from there a fruit
these are Williams pears pear is the
star of the chutney so keep it quite
rustic next add chopped cooking apples
their tireless gives a lovely contrast
to the sweetness of the pears to give it
great texture
a handful of salt on us into saffron
this gives it a really nice depth a rich
golden color saffron is the world's most
expensive spice it's made from the dried
stigmas of the saffron crocus flower and
as a general rule of thumb the deeper
the color of the threads the better the
quality and to make it lighter the zest
and juice of two oranges the orange and
the saffron go brilliantly well together
just squeeze that in there
this chutneys brilliant with ham
fantastic and sellers but equally is
delicious with fish whether it's a
roasted Cod a grilled filet of mackerel
it goes brilliantly well bring it up to
the ball
cook them out for 15 minutes now
tomatoes going at the end and that
brings a certain amount of freshness to
the chutney really help to give that
nice texture
[Music]
mix that in I literally cook it out for
30 seconds
[Music]
what's great about this chutney is that
as it matures its flavor gets better and
better and it will keep for up to six
months fill up the jar and that is gonna
deliver amazing flavor across Christmas
[Music]
hello my goodness me that is fit for a
king
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]